he he already as a child had been
binding himself with ropes and hanging
cats and
imagining you know
for him bondage was highly arousing
[Music]
hey sean yes sir howard man i am excited
about this gift and why is that well um
she's not like a she's not like a normal
guest she's not a police officer she's
not a lawyer she's not a criminal
she's more
she's definitely a criminologist and
works in that world but
she is the i guess you would call her
the academic of the law well yeah
looking at her bio without a doubt
clearly the
most educated person we have ever had on
here by far yeah more educated than you
and me and jason all put together
combined yes so uh she's worked on some
pretty high profile
cases she's been all over documentaries
she's written
numerous books
she works in clinical psychology
criminal psychology criminal forensics
there is just a ton of stuff a lot of
words that if i keep saying them i'm
gonna mispronounce basically everything
like television networks like discovery
or the id channel what they make their
shows
uh pretty much about what crime con
coming up in las vegas is about hey
we're going to be there we are going to
be there cocktails and cocktails
podcasts will be at crime con in las
vegas but anyways so today we have dr
catherine ramslin with us welcome ma'am
how you doing
i'm doing fine i'll be at crimecon 2.
get out of here oh really come by and
see you
have you been there before i have been
there once before once before right
before it closed down
for cove
yeah what should we wear then we is it
formal do we have to wear texas it's
well are you going to be on podcast row
it's informal
okay well that's how we roll we're
pretty informal so i'm wearing my bike
t-shirt yeah actually i'm we're excited
about it we did we got the invite for it
and um
same type of deal a couple years ago i'm
involved with another project and we
thought we were going to be there for
crime con and then the
as you mentioned that
everything shut down and never made it
out there so it's it's it's fantastic to
be back part of it it's first year so
looking forward to it we'll definitely
have to say hi to you
yeah i'll walk around and see you well
catherine you picked us a drink tonight
didn't you
i did pick a drink red blend red blend
well we we picked up some red blend too
it's called
boom boom
and we figured that you should you're
probably going to blow it up with all
these stories that's why we got boom
boom here well i got the 19 crimes i
figured that was appropriate
have you ever used the app to watch the
bottles talk
yes okay i know in the stores all the
time with it y'all know that is one of
the listen in the world of marketing for
any thing out there that definitely one
of the top ones i have ever seen
especially in that industry but it's
pretty fantastic doesn't snoop dogg have
one this is a snoop dogg does have one
yep snoop dogg does everything snoop
dogg desert he's on some other new show
on tv right now with like kelly clarkson
well miss rambling should we call you
doctor should we call you catherine what
do you like to go about catherine's fine
you can call me catherine all right
catherine will you have i'll start with
this you have a doctorate in philosophy
so any of our listeners think that they
want to have an argument with it don't
do it so tell us a little bit more about
your educational background and what you
do
yeah doctorate in philosophy and taught
logic for 15 years at rutgers university
so yeah you want to argue with me
and then and then i quit and i went back
to school to get a master's in forensic
psychology i already had one in clinical
psychology i then got one in criminal
justice and recently i got a master of
fine arts degree
my goodness huh and where'd the fine
arts come in what was that for i'm a
writer and it was it was a program at my
university
we got to travel to ireland
so why not
absolutely
um obviously nothing against your fine
arts degree in the writing but we
definitely would you know with with this
podcast here we would love to hear
some uh in in the world of the other
stuff that you've been you've been
working on
um that path how on earth you know after
getting out of being there at rutgers
what what put you on that path
what put me on that path was i was
writing for a website called the crime
library which was court tv's website
repository for crime stories and i was
writing one
case after another after another and i
thought if i went and got a masters in
forensic psychology that would be that
would enhance what i was doing but i
it changed my life essentially
now i'm a professor of forensic
psychology
and
that's what i do and i've written
numerous books since those early days
but it was really writing for the crime
library that got me started
well for dumb dumbs like me
can you explain what uh
forensic psychology is
forensic psychology is anywhere that
psychology crosses paths with the
investigation and court system so
anytime most forensic psychologists tend
to do things like competency
mental state of the time of the offense
so assessments for the court but you
could also be a consultant i do i
actually consult on death investigations
i do police trainings
um i
talk about profiling and
psychological autopsy which is really
about suicidology so
that's i have a whole class just in that
and i have a class in
dangerous minds that i teach at the
undergraduate and graduate level and
that is really about extreme offenders
which is mass murderers spree killers
and serial killers so that's primarily
what i do most of my work on and
most of
what the students want for me that class
fills up very quickly
yeah i could definitely see why now are
these classes if you don't mind what
university are you teaching through and
is this in person classes you're doing
or is this part of an online program
yeah i'm at the sales university in
pennsylvania and we did stay in the
classroom throughout the pandemic but i
also teach online i teach hybrid courses
where you're part part-time in the
classroom but a lot of it's also taking
place online so i do a lot of different
things but we were in the classroom
through that throughout the pandemic
so you got into this right basically
writing about these and you're like oh
this is pretty interesting stuff i'm
going to go back and study this so that
i can understand it a little bit better
so that i could write a little bit
better and obviously you went back to
learn to write a little bit better
because you understood what was going on
to make your stories more appealing i
know that was a lot of words as spit out
there but
here's my question
what really what was the one story that
you went that you were like yeah this is
my thing i want to do this
oh wow that's a huge question
a
multi-faceted career um
i didn't aspire to be an expert on
serial killers that is that was not
where i set my sights
but when i kept doing one story after
another after another for the crime
library
that became some books
i did a lot with um forensic science and
psychology
and then
suddenly i was being featured on a lot
of documentaries and news shows
and so that became my thing
more than
it chose me more than i chose it but i
love it i think it's really interesting
and i'm constantly finding
new
ideas new motivations you know we have
formulas related to serial killers but
for example i spent five years talking
with dennis rader the btk serial killer
because he does he defies many of the
formulas so i thought that was
interesting i wanted to know more about
that and i think i'm always looking for
the outliers
rather than the ones that fit the mold i
want to see the ones that don't fit the
mold and how do they get to be the way
they are and in psychology as opposed to
criminology
we're looking more at the cases the
individual details of someone's life
story
and and the trajectory basically whereas
in criminology you're looking more at
groups and trends and statistics and
things like that i'm much more
interested in just the case details so
that's why i like talking to people
who are willing to explore how they got
to be the way they are
and you know i can spend many hours
doing that so i didn't choose it but i'm
really happy i'm in this field
so so you said you know you didn't just
as you mentioned that you didn't choose
it it chose you kind of became i don't
want to say a fascination it just
obviously it's something you're very
successful in
as we know
society as a whole
whether it's through media or whatever
it is is obviously fascinated by serial
killers i mean the same document or
whether it be btk
or the night stalker or you know golden
state whatever you want to talk about
there's documentary after documentary or
movie or television show
and people just are drawn to them
um what do you think why
i mean you know why the public in
general the the housewives that are
living normal lives with getting the
kids up in the morning going to school
but they love to stay up at night and
watch these shows
yes it's interesting i've been watching
it for about 25 years and when i first
got involved in this field
it was
not the place you wanted to be
it was not i mean books like this didn't
sell
uh and very few people were interested
and then all of a sudden this boom boom
which really came out of csi i think csi
was a start in when they first aired
that show in 2001 or 2000 2000 into that
area
and people loved
the mystery they loved the puzzles
solving the puzzles and then as the
internet came up people could get into
these little clubs were amateur crime
solving and made them feel like they
were contributing something and this is
burgeoned into podcasting and and many
more of these kinds of things and i
really think that it's that that puzzle
factor people love the mystery but they
want to solve it and that's part of what
true wide the true crime fascination the
serial killers or spree or mass
murderers is really about how do people
get to the most extreme
aspect of this how do they
how do they become like this what are
they thinking why are they doing these
things and what do they think afterward
that too is a mystery and a puzzle that
people want to solve and in part i think
it's to to stay safe to feel safe if
they can figure it out
then that feels protective
so what i hear you saying is like the
serial killer is our modern-day
mythology boogeyman right it's the one
they definitely are yeah it's the one
that we're all scared of it's the one
that's going to kidnap a
teenage girl and
it's one of those fears that we have as
a society
yeah but i'm beginning to see that it's
becoming less potent yeah it's getting a
little stressful
yeah when you start seeing jokes and
funny shows about
that that start that's showing us that
society's becoming
uh so familiar with the formula that
they now feel like okay let's move on to
something else and and i think um the
boogeyman
part of the serial killer really is
fading well
we had another guest on a couple months
ago and
we had some discussion about serial
killers and i asked because i legit
didn't know i mean i was a cop for 25
years and i hadn't thought about this
but
a lot of the serial killer cases just
like the ones we're talking about that
are on tv the shows the podcast or
whatever it is it seems like it's stuff
from you know 90s 80s 70s 60s
or the the the world of quote unquote a
serial killer is it on
the decline because technology is better
in the way in the way of forensics of
catching people so people are getting
caught before they you know
obtain that status as a quote-unquote
serial killer
with cameras everywhere cell phone
whatever it may be
being a specialist that's in this field
do you think
as time continues on are we going to
have a i guess like i said a decline in
the number of
people that are considered quote unquote
serial killers
i well first of all the definition
changed from at least three murders and
three incidents to two
which suddenly expanded the database
massively
so comparing today to before 2005 when
that definition changed in in the fbi in
the united states
um is hard to do because
it's almost apples to oranges in a way
but around the world we still see a lot
of serial killers too there's one theory
that i know of that claims the golden
age of the 60s 70s 80s was the golden
age of serial killers and in part that's
because that was the big media focus it
it was fascinating there was ted bundy
john wayne gacy the zodiac all these
these big time
names that we that we're very familiar
with and the ones that we hear about now
don't have that star quality so they're
still out there they're still
being covered by media but not in the
way that they were in the 70s and 80s so
in part it's because we have a very
different media approach to them
yes i think there's some decline i'm not
sure i would say it's a significant
decline but certainly forensics has made
a difference especially in those
predators who study
how to get away with murder
they're having a harder time at it but
then look at sam little
who claimed 93 victims over several
decades
and first of all he he was black
for from you know there was this formula
back in the 70s of there's so few black
serial killers and you know that's not
true it's just that there's so few media
genic
serial killers that's part of it is what
is the media focusing on
um but but he would then be considered
if if all of those cases were
corroborated which they are not he would
be you know we'd have the record in the
united states
and he he just surfaced recently
the golden the golden state killer
another one who got away with it for
many years
so
it's hard to make those comparisons and
like i said i don't really
like trend analysis as much as i like
case analysis so i personally don't pay
much attention to the trends
i think if they if they are diminishing
it's a lot of factors and i don't know
that it's necessarily
going to to predict the future for us
on that score well earlier you said um
that you like to study what happened to
these individuals that made them a
serial killer is there any kind of under
i mean is it they weren't hugged by
their dad or what's the underlying
current there you know
it's there isn't a factor that is in
common to them all you we could talk
about head injuries i can name any
number of killers who never had a head
injury or child abuse or
any of those things neglect deprivation
these are the common factors that we
look at but but there are certainly
serial killers who did not have those
things happen to them so i think that
there's a lot of diversity in the serial
killer population and that we to
understand them you take it case by case
rather than as any kind of formula
what is the most fascinating case the
one that's held your interest the the
longest what is that one been that you
can speak of
i'd say jack the ripper
yeah because i i don't agree
that there were five victims
i don't even think the five the jack
or jack or jill or if it's jack is they
who knows we don't know
um i don't necessarily think the
canonical five as they call it
i don't think they're necessarily all
part of the mix
and i think that some of the primitive
ideas about jack the ripper from 1888
have bled into much of what we think but
i've met a lot of ripperologists i've
been to white chapel several times
and there's so much debate there's i
read one book that was 333 suspects
333 and i knew that they didn't have
them all as soon as i finished the book
i could think of a couple more that they
didn't have in the book
and every one of them has a supporter
saying we know this is the person and
we don't know we don't know that there
is one person called jack the ripper so
it isn't it isn't that killer that
fascinates me but the
um all the
different aspects of that case that need
to be looked at so it's fascinating it's
a mystery it's a puzzle unidentified
quote unquote serial killer was a late
1800s something like that right london
80s 1888 or 1887
to 1891 or it depends depends on how
many victims you want to put in there
when you're doing your forensic study on
something like that you're going through
historical records what historical
records do you go through do you go
through the i assume the media of the
time but what else would you go through
yeah you definitely look at the media of
the time
that's important but
you certainly try to get police records
if you can
some you'd be hindered somewhat if you
can't speak the language of another
country where there's a kill you're
trying to search for
um if you is collectors people who are
ripperologists i i often go to them for
this or to
zodiac maniacs
some people
call them um you know there are there
are people who spend their entire lives
on a case and so they are often quite
good sources of information
but i i haven't yet really found a case
that i want to spend
my entire life on obviously have well
can you get a degree in ripperology
you can't oh i don't know i'm not in
england maybe you can i don't know i
imagine if you could you would i don't
think so but i've spent a fair amount of
time and every time someone asks me
is there some
person dead or alive that you'd want to
have dinner with i always say jack the
ripper because then i'd know who it is
oh who it is and you could eliminate
someone
yeah you would be very rich and you
could eliminate off that 300-plus list
clear a lot of people's names right 333
he didn't do it right
what was the and just because we're
talking i try to just google it right
here and i can't remember what state it
or what country it is i thought it was
el salvador there was some guy in the
last couple years that's claimed to be
i mean a serial killer of some
astronomical number do you know what
you're doing 350 yes exactly yeah pedro
yeah south america yes yes somewhere
down in south america i was curious if
you'd look you know even looked into
anything about that at all or
yes and the cl you know a lot of serial
killers exaggerated absolutely
so
you always have to take with a grain of
salt especially if they're trying to
compete with somebody
exactly we we lie about a lot of uh
accomplishments okay 87. let's put it
that way i'm not going to say that yeah
trust me we're all thinking the same
thing yeah we know
but i remember one serial killer in
colorado who claimed 49 and i said i
wonder if that's because gary ridgway
has 48.
and
they couldn't corroborate almost any of
the ones he was making a claim for so
you always have to wonder but i do
believe they did find in that case quite
a lot of bodies in that case i don't
know if it was as many as he was
claiming but there were a lot well i
asked him in your career you've come
face to face with a lot of these
gentlemen correct
yeah
i would not not i'm like you can't just
go into prisons and come face to face
with them but yeah i've talked to them
on the phone
through correspondence sometimes in
prison
have you ever gotten that just like this
is just pure evil this guy is just
he's there's nothing i have a hard time
with the word evil okay gotcha all right
because it's kind of a religious context
do i think have i come face to face with
psychopaths absolutely the coldness the
lack of remorse definitely
um so some people yeah some people call
that evil but we are finding that it
might very well be a brain disorder
huh
neuroscience is giving us a lot of
information about the brains of
psychopaths and they are they do process
things differently they are very shallow
emotional connections
um is it something they're born with if
so
that's a different story
i wonder if you can test that on 23 in
may
find that out yeah
scandinavian psychopath
there is it there's a guy in new mexico
who's scanned the brains of of thousands
of inmates and also compare them to
normal people and finds you know around
the world they're doing this work now
the brains of what we call primary
psychopaths who seem to be
born with this
brain disconnect
are definitely different and it allows
them to be better predators if that's
what they choose to be not all
psychopaths are criminals not all
psychopaths are murderers but if they
choose that it allows them to be very
effective at it because they really
don't have any remorse over what they're
doing and they really can be very
calculated they tend to be very reward
driven
um so the brain is different well and
you know just kind of talk about one of
the ones uh
as you said that kind of defies um
you know the typical serial killer just
just as you're describing right there
was the btk killer and you did
you said you had conversations with him
and and so forth is that correct
yeah i've known him for 11 years now we
spent five years working on his
what i call a guided autobiography
that is he wanted to tell his story i
wanted it to be useful for criminology
psychology and law enforcement so i
guided him toward thinking about things
that we would find useful
so yeah five years though
it was quite a i wouldn't have guessed
it would take that long but it did the
and did he go into you know detail going
through i mean obviously i'm sure his
upbringing but did he cover how many
murders was he convicted for 10 12
something like that
did did he go through even talking about
those you know each of those murders or
why he did anything
in detail in detail yeah and the one
that he had anticipated committing
just as he was
he got arrested he already had one in
mind it was going to be the the worst of
all of them but yeah in detail
what
okay so share that with us what was his
gateway what was the what was the final
thing that made him go okay i'm gonna
start killing people
well in part and this this actually goes
back to that theory of the golden age of
serial killers the sexually compelled
serial killers that we spend a lot of
media
energy on
uh
a lot of them have talked about those
true detective magazines in the 1950s
and 60s of scantily clad bound terrified
women that they fixated on he's one of
those when he was 14 he found a magazine
under the
uh seated
the driver's seat of his dad's car
and it
as he's developing into a sexual
person he's
devouring these magazines he already had
been binding himself and and it was
feeling good to him so bondage
that image of a terrified woman his
his deci his desire to dominate women
because women had humiliated him
um and his desire to be famous and he
saw on these magazines stories about h.h
holmes and harvey glattman and people
like that and then he saw all the media
attention to
ted bundy and some of the 70s serial
killers and he wanted that too
so his fantasy life is what propelled
him he was thinking all about these
things and imagining himself as one of
those elite serial killers and so when
he then he saw a woman and her daughter
walking and he followed them home and he
looked at the house and he
met he already had envisioned himself in
this kind of spy james bond way
so he decided just to go do it let's try
it and right before then he had actually
tried he had already been breaking into
houses
and he had tried to abduct somebody in a
parking lot that had failed
but this time he went into the house
and he took total command of the of the
family he killed four people in his
first time out
geez so he just this just came from
cusatic thinking right he just
he just romanticized it he i mean it was
just like yeah this is what i want to do
yeah there's such an issue
he he already as a child had been
binding himself with ropes and hanging
cats and imagining you know
for him bondage was highly arousing he
had um imagine girl trapping girls tying
them to railroad tracks
all of that was part of his fantasy life
and as he
came into
being a man and this at this point
he was also married
um
then during his
his spate of murders he had two children
he was the president of his church
congregation he was a competent
work person i mean he wasn't like a so
you know pick up jobs and somebody
couldn't hold on a job he had jobs in
fact he was installing security systems
so he knew exactly how to break into
houses
you know
let me ask you this about his so he was
married had kids did his relationship
with his wife was it
you know
is that how their sexual relationship
was as well he liked to you know bound
her and stuff like this or was this the
fantasy
he was able to act it out i mean he
thought differently of her he was able
to act this out on his victims basically
on his victims also he had these uh cut
out
dolls that he would take with them to
work they were a little from magazines
and whatnot he had him on he stuck them
on cards and so so they were his
imaginary dates and he he had once
approached his wife she didn't want
anything to do with that so whatever and
he found he'd go off on work trips and
he'd have what he called motel parties
where he had these his little barbie
dolls and
and things and he'd create these
elaborate bondage scenarios for himself
in a hotel room
so this first family of four of the
first victims did he tied them up and or
was it just a yes
wow bound them
put them in different rooms went from
room to room choking them and then when
he had killed the parents and a little
boy he took the the 11 year old girl
into the basement and hanged her
it was pretty gruesome yeah absolutely
and i honestly don't know the answer why
is he where did the btk come from
he named himself
bind them torture them kill them he put
in when he about about he had killed one
more victim after that and with an
attempted murder on her brother and so
eight months after his first murder nine
months after his first murder he saw
that the police had picked up three
guys that they thought were good
suspects for that that family murder
and he didn't like that
because they were wasting his taxpayer
dollars and so he wrote a letter that
was his first communication to
the police he actually wrote it he had a
newspaper person go get it
but
pretty soon he wanted to give himself a
name he wanted to wichita kansas to know
that they had a serial killer in their
presence
so he began to communicate and he didn't
want to leave his name to chance because
he knew serial killers get these media
names so he named himself and basically
said you'll know it's me because here's
my symbol and out of the btk he made a
kind of vulgar looking female form
because that was he wanted it to be very
sexualized
so did he have sex with his victims or
was it just a it was just the fantasy of
binding them torturing them and killing
them and then he would just masturbate
or what
yeah yeah he did not have sex with them
but he did masturbate yes sometimes at
the scene sometimes later he would take
items like their their slips and
underwear he would take that with him
and it was
you know trophy souvenirs he'd take
and so he could relive that sometimes at
one point he stole a polaroid camera and
he took some pictures of a victim
several victims that way once
he took a a woman out of her house after
he killed her took her to his church
and he had he had put
black plastic around the windows in the
room he'd already prepared it and
dressed the corpse in various items of
underwear he had stolen from other homes
and took pictures of her
posing in this but she wasn't posing
because she was dead but that's what he
did
well that photo shoot would have been
weird i need you to be more natural
you're acting a little stiff no kidding
so during this whole time
you're you're interviewing him and he's
speaking and i assume he's speaking
fairly candid with you because you have
a good relationship and you've
actually gained his trust
was there ever a period where you were
like
hold the fuck on i can't listen to this
anymore for a few minutes i need a break
did
i i
that that level of
sharing
is is a lot for someone to take so how
did you deal with that
yeah well
he partly wrote these in letters he'd
write very long letters to me describing
everything that was one thing and on the
phone
we always talked in codes because he
wanted to always make sure nobody could
figure out because in you know prisons
they're recorded
yeah so he so everything was in codes
which buffered it a little bit
but there were times i had some good
friends i would go to and say okay you
guys need to hear this because i need to
share the burden so
so
they're still my friends
as a matter of fact
sometimes i just had to go talk to
somebody because it it became revolting
yeah i can't i mean it's so far and just
removed from humanity you know i mean
that
that break with humanity
well he you know he would refer to his
victims as projects so that was his
distancing mechanism he had he gave me
even though he killed 10 he gave me a
list of 55 targets
with full descriptions of where they
lived and how he had stalked them and
what had happened and why it hadn't
worked out so he was on the move quite a
lot
and uh
yeah he he enjoyed it but the fact that
he would call them projects and he'd
name them like project lights out
project cookie project piano that that i
believe helped him to objectify them and
make them less than human
yeah well it became
it was hard for me because i didn't want
to think about a
11 year old girl being hanged from a
basement pipe
um as just a project because she wasn't
absolutely not well he
kind of wrap up talking about the btk
here but his last um
i guess the one he had planned that was
going to be his most gruesome or you
know biggest one ever in his words
what was that about that you know
luckily never happened
well he
depends on what day you ask him because
he's changed his story but it was going
to be like his retirement this is in
part it was he had he had stopped
communicating with the police
um before the 1980s in fact so
they weren't really sure if they were
connecting all the murders they thought
they had seven they didn't know for sure
they had ten
but he seemed to have stopped in 1991
with the last one and then all of a
sudden in 2004 he came out
to say here i am i'm still in wichita
and he wanted then to make a big splash
by killing somebody because he wanted to
create terror in
you know in the whole area
but he made a mistake he kept
communicating and then one day
what he would do is go he'd copy
the things he'd written and then copy
the copies copy the copies and that was
getting time-consuming so he asked him
if he could communicate with a
computer disk could they trace him
and they were to put in the newspaper
rex because that was the name of his
penis
rex
it will be okay t-rex can't do push-ups
right exactly
and he bought it and sent the disc and
they traced him and got him
and he asked the first thing he asked
was why did you lie to me
and the head of the task force ken
landwear said
we were trying to catch you yeah exactly
believe it or not people police
we do lie to people
it happens
and he knew that he had he had a masters
in criminal or ba in criminal justice he
knew that he had classes he had a
pathologist giving a lecture on the btk
victims when he's sitting right in there
watching him wow
god i bet you he was smug as shit in
that class
so what was this this last case or this
last you know grand idea that he had had
as you said depending on what day you
you spoke with them but would you kind
of land on
well he he had identified a woman he
always needed people with routines
because then he could plan plan it out
and figure out you know when they'd be
off guard when was the easiest time
he had a very elaborate um idea of all
these ropes and bondage he was going to
hang her upside down and and
he had stored a bunch of semen
he's going to put it all over the house
and then burn the house so how that
works i don't know but he had a very
elaborate plan for this final one
because he really wanted to show i'm out
here and maybe there'll be another one
after this
him and rex
him and rex
okay well um where is he currently and
how long
is he going to stay in jail
but he's a life and there's no parole
for him he's in el dorado
uh kansas and
and he'll be there until he dies he's in
a he's not in general population he's in
his own
cell
and that's where he'll stay
as he should absolutely so what so what
what about you what's going forward here
i know uh
obviously you're still heavily involved
in this you've got other projects
um you know what's your name
projects oh yeah actually terrible
terrible oh terrible
she's got you on that one terrible
terrible decision i haven't even had a
glass a sip of my wine yet wait what
happened
she's sharp
yeah that was pretty what's hershey
she's got 37 degrees she does have she
does have a ripperology one yes all
right let's see you you have other um
what's the word i need to find i don't
want to use this other path
future plans future plans yes cases yes
i do indeed
i'm actually writing a novel series
featuring a forensic psychologist who
owns an investigation firm
and takes on cases that are difficult
and twisty
so and she's a suicidologist
like i am so she consults on death
investigations that have
tricky aspects to them and i'm having a
blast i love i love writing fiction and
i will have another probably another
book not quite like raider but another
one like that similar you think you're
qualified
to write such uh such a series slandest
modest yeah like
you know
[Laughter]
well i guess my fans if there are any
readers will tell me if i'm qualified or
not but i'm having a blast i've actually
written fiction before and so it's fun
to come back to it and it's it's just a
nice way to
start moving out of this all of this
stuff because the btk thing was intense
we also did a four part documentary on a
e from the book
interviewing him again for a number of
hours
for that and that was that was that just
aired in january so will there be more
also i have a show called murder house
flip
and it's in its second season so that's
that's a show that i that came out of
one of my classes well explain that to
us what's murder house flip somebody get
murdered and i think that's at this
design show where you take a house where
a murder has occurred and we re redesign
it to heal the murder space so the
family that owns it can be more
comfortable in their home
no kidding
that's a hard sell isn't it
oh they said that everyone loved it we
pitched it everywhere
i it was a blast we've we had one season
already dorothy puente's house who's the
serial killer who ran a boarding house
and buried seven bodies in her yard we
redid their yard for them
it's beautiful
so yeah it's great and you guys are
working
working on a season two for that now huh
yeah
the houses have already been filmed
no kidding and where's that aired at
well it started on quibby if you know
the streaming service quibby uh they
they took a dive during the pandemic and
we thought we were going to lose it but
then roku bought everything of quibby so
it's on roku originals now nice
we like okay so here's here's my final
question out of all of all of the
other than jack the ripper all of the
ones that you've looked at what has been
the one that you're like i can't figure
this out at all
i'm just stumped here
i was stumped that's a hard one
um
can't figure it out
yeah you can't figure that figure the
motivation find who's done it
make a
find the path to it or do you just find
them after they've already confessed to
it
you help investigations too correct
yeah i've i've consulted on
investigations but they're they're not
that hard to figure out i mean that
they're not that puzzling i know i know
tv fiction loves to make them into
masterminds but generally they're not
but i think israel keys
was interesting in that respect he was
an
alaskan serial killer but he he wanted
to be ted bundy without making bundy's
mistakes
so he'd go to some area buy things for a
murder kit pl
bury it or hide it somewhere and then
come back maybe in a year or two
and just kill somebody who came his way
until he at the end made mistakes now
we know about three of his murders he
claimed at least eight more we don't
know if there really are eight more or
not and then he committed suicide
so you know what's the point of doing
that what's the point why why just
murder people he was
everyone liked this guy he
you know what was his problem that's
that's a hard one well what let's
distinguish here too serial killers kind
of are well planned out and they hunt
their individuals alone but then there's
mass murder some some are
predators are but they're not all some
are psychotic they're completely dis
disorganized well what about the brains
of people who do mass shootings who walk
into a workplace and
shoot 10 of their co-workers or they're
pissed off at a company and they walk
into a fedex distribution center and
just start shooting it up what's the
difference in
one their mind versus
like a serial killer's mind
well they've they're they have a
as a temperament
typically and there are more there's
more homogeneity in the mass murderer
than there is in the serial killer so so
there's more similar to one another
anger rigidity
um feelings of entitlement think they
didn't get what they wanted they don't
like how the world is either treating
them or how the world's turning out they
want to punish people
often they're suicidal they want to go
out but they want to go out with a
splash some are looking for fame if i
get the most
victims about anybody in the world
people will remember me so they have a
variety of motives but but but their
personalities tend to have that rigidity
and that
inability to go with life's hard knocks
and to believe that they're entitled to
more
and that they need to punish people for
them not getting what they think they
deserve
or they're terrorists which is another
thing because
they might have a mission if they have a
mission that requires them to kill a lot
of people that's a very different type
of mindset so we have a variety of
different mass murders family mass
murderers are about wiping out their
family
sometimes suicidally or sometimes so
they can start over so you really kind
of there there are different categories
of mass murder but the the one you're
talking about the workplace one tend to
have that
you know angry
entitled thing going are you familiar
with just talking about uh
you know wiping out the family the the
story here and
suburb it's also called broken arrow
oklahoma just literally right outside
the city i think the last name was the
bevers the teenage kids that
killed mom dad little little one stuff
like that you follow that or
have you ever looked into that that that
legit the house across the street from
my old house that i was living in the
house right behind that is where they
lived at
um when that happened and there's like
this little ravine that runs near my
house is actually where they got caught
at
and just yeah this is a community that i
think averages maybe one homicide a year
it was actually one of the safest cities
in america a couple years ago and then
something like that happened there
yeah sometimes when kids do it it's
either because of abuse or because they
are
mentally ill unstable
and paranoid often
have have some kind of undiagnosed
disorder that hasn't been treated but
but sometimes it's really about abuse
and they're just
reacting yeah well catherine we have had
a fascinating talk with you
it's amazing the stories that you share
and we'll definitely see you at crimecon
absolutely i'll be looking for you